the prime suspect in the murder of an
American teacher in South Korea is
speaking out for the very first time
Carolyn Abel was killed in her apartment
30 years ago while teaching English and
Seoul the main suspect was not arrested
and because of US extradition laws her
alleged killer may never face trial 48
hours correspondent Peter Van Sant
investigated her murder case for nearly
three years and in this week's 48 hours
he confronts the accused killer so this
is one of the last pictures taken of her
alive right
Denver attorney Wanda Abel forever
misses her younger sister Carolyn who
was teaching English in Seoul South
Korea in 1988 when she was murdered
stabbed to death in her apartment
Carolyn's apartment was ransacked and it
appeared to be a robbery gone bad
her fellow teachers like Nancy Birkhoff
were frightened not only were we
devastated about the loss of Carolyn
we of course wondered who's next John
Boatwright a chief of detectives in
South Korea for the Army's Criminal
Investigation Division was brought on
the case to assist I was convinced
whoever did this probably knew Caroline
why because it was no science for
attention to the apartment he decided to
interview the two American teachers who
discovered Carolyn's body
Kathy Patrick and Sandra Ames under
questioning Ames made a shocking
accusation that her roommate Kathy
murdered Carolyn and staged the scene to
look like a robbery that never occurred
to any of us that the killer was among
us
who do you believe held the knife and
murdered
Carolyn Abel Kathy Patrick South Korean
officials issued this warrant for
Patrick's arrest but she had moved back
to Washington State investigators there
quickly learned they were powerless to
arrest Patrick because the u.s. and
South Korea didn't have an extradition
treaty my sister never got to live her
life
why does Kathy it's a little full life
Kathy turned down our request for an
interview this is the building so we
went to her office at Western Washington
University where Kathy Patrick is a
guidance counselor there are
investigators from two countries that
have now I are certain that you murdered
Carolyn Abel what do you have to say I
have to say that these are Kathy
Patrick's first public words on the
murder of Carolyn Abel in 30 years there
were 30 stab wounds on Carolyn's body
and friends say that they attacked her
after she rejected you your romantic
advances no this has to stop now please
Wow
Peter my mouth is still open number one
by the way you walked in the office and
just said they say you murdered her and
the fact that she sat down and even
talked to you whatsoever clearly the
family believes that she's getting away
with murder can she ever be prosecuted
it's highly unlikely even though there
was a murder warrant in South Korea for
her arrest she had already come back to
the United States and there was no
extradition treaty to get her back there
also Carolyn Abel the victim's family
has been told that the evidence in Korea
has been destroyed the police files have
been destroyed have US laws changed
since then US laws have changed thanks
to Carolyn Abel's family now if an
American kills an American overseas they
can be tried here in the United States
what's that like you walk in and you're
going to accuse somebody of murder it
could go many ways what are you thinking
look at this is the end of three years
and we have talked to a dozen people
involved in this case who's all all
there
lives were altered this was a very
satisfying moment to go in there and
confront her with with these allegations
it was an important moment there's a lot
more in the show Saturday night of my
conversation there she answered about
five questions perfect segue you can see
Peters report we're calling it out of
reach tomorrow night on 48 hours it airs
at 10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS